FOX NEWS ALERT.
EXPLOSIVE COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS SCANDAL HAS LANDED
TWO HOLLYWOOD ACTRESSES IN BIG
TROUBLE WITH THE LAW.
FELICITY HUFFMAN AND LORI
LOUGHLIN ARE AMONG DOZENS OF
PEOPLE CHARGED IN A 25
MILLION-DOLLAR BRIBERY SCHEME.
AUTHORITY'S A RICH PARENTS
BRIBED, CHEATED AND DEFRAUDED IN
ORDER TO GET THE KIDS INTO SOME
OF THE COUNTRY'S MOST ELITE
SCHOOLS.
THE ALLEGED CRIMES INCLUDE
PAYING FOR SOMEONE TO TAKE THEIR
KIDS S.A.T.s, PAYING AN
ADMISSIONS CONSULTANT TO BRIBED
COACHES INTO LABELING THEIR KIDS
AS RECRUITED ATHLETES TO BOOST
THEIR CHANCES, AND ALSO FAKING
ATHLETIC PROFILES TO MAKE
STUDENTS LOOK LIKE STRONG
ATHLETES WHEN THEY ACTUALLY
WEREN'T.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE SCHOOL
ADMISSIONS WERE INVOLVED IN ANY
OF THE WRONGDOING.
THE U.S. ATTORNEY IN CHARGE
DESCRIBING THE BOMBSHELL
ALLEGATIONS.
>> THE PARENTS CHARGE TODAY,
DESPITE ALREADY BEING ABLE TO
GIVE THEIR CHILDREN EVERY
LEGITIMATE ADVANTAGE OF THE
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS GAME, INSTEAD
CHOSE TO CORRUPT AND ILLEGALLY
MANEUVER LATE THE SYSTEM FOR
THEIR BENEFIT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT DONATING
A BUILDING SO THAT A SCHOOL IS
MORE LIKELY TO TAKE YOUR SON OR
DAUGHTER.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT DECEPTION
AND FRAUD, FATE TEST SCORES,
FAKE ATHLETIC CREDENTIALS, FAKE
PHOTOGRAPHS, BRIBED COLLEGE
OFFICIALS.
>> Jesse: FELICITY HUFFMAN IS
EXPECTED IN COURT THIS HOUR
WHILE LORI LOUGHLIN IS
APPARENTLY ON A FLIGHT BACK TO
L.A. WHERE SHE IS EXPECTED TO
SURRENDER TO AUTHORITIES.
FOR MORE, LET'S GO TO
JONATHAN HUNT, LIVE AT THE
COURTHOUSE IN L.A. WITH THE
LATEST.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
FELICITY HUFFMAN, THE ACTRESS,
FAMED FOR HER ROLE IN "DESPERATE
HOUSEWIVES," AMONG 13 PEOPLE DO
TO APPEAR THIS HOUR IN THE
FEDERAL COURT BEHIND ME.
SHE, AS WELL AS THE ACTRESS LORI
LOUGHLIN ARE TWO OF DOZENS
ACCUSED OF TAKING PART IN WHAT
WAS A WIDE-RANGING SCHEME,
ESSENTIALLY TO BRIBE AND DEFRAUD
THE COLLEGE ADMISSIONS SYSTEM TO
GET THEIR CHILDREN INTO COLLEGES
THAT THOSE PARENTS PRESUMABLY
THOUGHT THEY OTHERWISE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO GET INTO.
FELICITY HUFFMAN AND HER HUSBAND
WILLIAM H. MACY ACCUSED OF
PAYING 15,000 TO ALTER S.A.T.
TEST SCORES.
LORI LOUGHLIN AND HER HUSBAND,
WHO IS THE DESIGNER, ARE ACCUSED
OF PAYING $500,000 TO HAVE THEIR
TWO DAUGHTERS LABELED AS
RECRUITS TO THE USC CREW TEAM.
NEITHER OF THOSE DAUGHTERS EVER
TOOK PART IN THAT SPORT.
THIS WAS A WIDE-RANGING SCHEME,
ONE ESSENTIALLY RUN BY A COMPANY
THAT WAS RUN OUT OF
NEWPORT BEACH, CALIFORNIA, BY A
MAN CALLED WILLIAM SINGER.
HE PLEADED GUILTY EARLIER TODAY
TO RACKETEERING.
WE ASSUME HE HAS GIVEN THE FEDS
MUCH OF THE EVIDENCE ON WHICH
ALL OF THESE CHARGES ARE BASED.
WE WILL NOW HAVE THE 13 HERE IN
L.A. ARRAIGNED.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN FELICITY
HUFFMAN AT THIS POINT, ALTHOUGH
SHE SHOULD, BY ALL LOGIC, BE
INSIDE THE COURTHOUSE ALREADY.
WE HAVE SEEN HER HUSBAND,
WILLIAM H. MACY.
HE WAS ASKED IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON THE CASE, HIS ANSWER
WAS NO.
>> Jesse: GREAT GET, JONATHAN.
GREG, YOU ARE A BIG FAN OF "FULL
HOUSE" AND "DESPERATE
HOUSEWIVES."
ARE YOU TAKING THIS
EXCEPTIONALLY HARD?
>> Greg: I AM DAMAGED BY THE
NEWS.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT THE
SCANDAL, IS WHEN THEY MAKE THE
MOVIE, EVERYONE CAN PLAY
THEMSELVES.
WHO CAN PLAY FELICITY HUFFMAN
BETTER THAN FELICITY HUFFMAN.
>> Dana: I LIKE
WILLIAM H. MACY.
>> Greg: THERE'S A COUPLE
THINGS.
PEOPLE ARE AS SINFUL AS THEIR
OPTIONS ALLOW THEM TO BE.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF IF THIS
OPTION WERE ALLOWED FOR YOU TO
HELP YOUR KID GET A LEG UP,
WOULD YOU DO IT?
WE CAN DISLIKE WHAT THEY DO BUT
WE HAVE TO WONDER, WHAT IF WE
HAVE THAT OPTION?
IT DOES SHOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
REALLY ENJOY THE STORY BECAUSE
WE HAVE A BIOLOGICAL REVULSION
TO LINE CUTTING.
EVERYONE HATES ALL KINDS OF LINE
CUTTING, WHETHER IT'S ACTUAL
LINE CUTTING OR IMMIGRATION OR
COLLEGE ADMISSION.
IT BUGS US.
WE ARE PROGRAMMED TO BE
DISGUSTED BY PEOPLE WHO DON'T
GET THERE THE RIGHT WAY.
>> Jesse: BRIBING THE COYOTES,
CUTTING IN LINE IN FRONT OF
OTHER PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THIS IS WHY I ONLY
HAVE HOUSEPLANTS AND NOT KIDS.
I DON'T NEED TO GREASE A
GARDENERS PALM TO GET HIM TO
TRIM MY BOX WAS.
STUPID KIDS ARE A PROBLEM.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT THERE WERE
OTHER REASONS YOU DIDN'T HAVE
KIDS.
EVERYBODY'S INTERESTED, THERE'S
THE LINE CUTTING.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT HARD TIMES.
ONE OF THE RECORDED
CONVERSATIONS SOMEBODY SAID I'M
NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE MORAL PART
OF THINGS.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
HAPPEN IF WE GET CAUGHT.
>> Dana: YOU'RE GOING TO BE
EMBARRASSED.
WHAT DRIVES IT IS THE FAIRNESS
ISSUE.
EVERYBODY IN THE WORLD, HUMAN
BEING IS BORN.
FAIRNESS IS INNATE IN YOU.
MAKING MONEY BY HELPING RICH
PEOPLE GET THEIR ALREADY
PRIVILEGED KIDS EVEN MORE
PRIVILEGED SO THEY CAN MAKE MORE
MONEY, IT SEEMS LIKE THE SYSTEM
IS RIGGED.
THE SYSTEM IS WORKING AGAINST
YOU.
KUDOS TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FBI
WHO WENT AHEAD AND GOT THESE
GUYS INSTEAD WERE NOT GOING TO
PUT UP WITH THIS ANYMORE.
I DON'T HAVE CHILDREN EITHER BUT
I HAVE PLENTY OF FRIENDS THAT DO
AND I KNOW THAT THEY START
TALKING ABOUT PAYING FOR COLLEGE
BEFORE THE BABIES ARE EVEN
CONCEIVED.
YOU START WONDERING HOW MIKE AND
MAKE THIS HAPPEN?
GETTING YOUR CHILD INTO COLLEGE
NOW IS LIKE A PART-TIME JOB AND
KIDS DON'T HAVE PART-TIME JOBS
BECAUSE IT'S THEIR JOB TO TRY TO
GET INTO COLLEGE.
THEY NEED TO HAVE ALL THE
REQUISITE THINGS.
I'M GLAD THEY CAUGHT THEM.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S MORE
WIDESPREAD.
THEY FOUND THESE GUYS BUT THIS
IS HAPPENING ELSEWHERE?
>> Jesse: LIKE DANA SAID,
PARENTS ARE THINKING, DID MY SON
OR DAUGHTER NOT GET INTO THE
SCHOOL BECAUSE SOME RICH FAT CAT
BRIBED TO COACH?
>> Juan: RIGHT.
THIS IS NOT A VICTIMLESS CRIME.
THERE ARE REAL PEOPLE WHO
SUFFERED AS A RESULT OF LOST
OPPORTUNITY.
GETTING INTO THE VERY BEST
SCHOOLS IN THE COUNTRY.
TO ME, THERE'S A BIGGER STORY
HERE.
THERE'S A LAWSUIT RIGHT NOW IT'S
BEEN PUT FORWARD BY
CONSERVATIVES USING ASIANS TO
CHALLENGE AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AT
HARVARD.
IN THE COURSE OF THAT DEBATE,
HERE'S WHAT WE FOUND.
RIGHT NOW IF YOU LOOK AT
SELECTIVE SCHOOLS, IF YOU HAVE A
LEGACY, THAT'S WHAT THESE PEOPLE
-- WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
ATHLETICS.
LEGACIES, IF YOU WENT TO THE
SCHOOL AND THEN APPLIED FOR YOUR
KIDS, THAT'S EVEN BIGGER THAN
ATHLETICS.
34% ADMITTED FIVE TIMES HIGHER
THAN PEOPLE WHOSE PARENTS DID
NOT GO TO SCHOOL.
IF YOU WANT TO HARVARD, YOU ARE
ALREADY RICH ENTITLED ON FAMOUS
AND YOUR KID APPLIES, TREMENDOUS
ADVANTAGE ESPECIALLY IF THE KID
HAS GOOD ENOUGH GRADES.
THE MOST PRIVILEGED KIDS IN
AMERICA GET THE BIGGEST BOOST.
NOT THE BLACK KIDS, NOT THE
ASIAN KIDS, NOT THE HISPANIC
KIDS.
THE SECOND POINT TO MAKE IS IF
YOU HAVE AN ATHLETIC CREDENTIAL
ON YOUR RESUME WHICH IS WHAT
THESE FRAUDSTERS WERE DOING,
THEY WERE PUTTING PICTURES OF
THEIR KIDS ON THE BODIES OF
ATHLETES AND PUSHING IT OUT
THERE.
IF YOU'RE AN ATHLETE, GUESS
WHAT, YOU HAVE ABOUT A 50% BOOST
IN TERMS OF YOUR LIKELIHOOD TO
GET INTO A SCHOOL.
ONE LAST POINT, MOST OF THE
ATHLETES IN AMERICA, DESPITE THE
BLACK BEST BUY PLAYERS AND
FOOTBALL, MOST COLLEGE ATHLETES
ARE WHITE.
THE CROSS, CREW, ICE HOCKEY.
>> Jesse: SQUASH.
>> Greg: NOBODY BROUGHT
UPGRADES.
>> Juan: THE CONSERVATIVES ARE
USING ASIANS TO CHALLENGE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION AT HARVARD AS
IF --
>> Dagen: LET'S TALK ABOUT --
>> Greg: I'M NOT SURE HOW WE
GOT INTO THE ASIAN QUESTION.
>> Dagen: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
PEOPLE NAMED IN THE COMPLAINT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ADVANCING THEIR
KIDS AND MAKING THEIR LIVES
BETTER DOWN THE ROAD.
THEY ARE EMBARRASSED BY THEIR
DUMB KIDS AND THEY COULDN'T GET
INTO A DECENT SCHOOL.
IF YOU READ THE COMPLAINT AND I
DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE THE SOUND
OF IT BUT IF YOU GO ONLINE,
OLIVIA JADE, ONE OF LORI
LOUGHLIN'S KIDS, HAS YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.
SHE HAD A CAREER BEFORE SHE EVER
HAD TO GO TO USC, WHICH SHE GOT
INTO APPARENTLY BECAUSE THEY
PAID $500,000, HER PARENTS, FOR
THE TWO KIDS TO GET INTO USC TO
BE ON THE CREW TEAM.
>> Jesse: I THINK WE HAVE SOME
SOUND OF LORI LOUGHLIN'S
DAUGHTER THAT WE CAN LISTEN TO.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH OF
SCHOOL I'M GOING TO ATTEND BUT
I'M GOING TO GO IN AND TALK TO
MY DEANS AND EVERYONE AND HOPE I
CAN TRY TO BALANCE IT ALL.
I DO WANT THE EXPERIENCE OF GAME
DAY PARTYING.
I DON'T REALLY CARE ABOUT
SCHOOL, AS YOU ALL KNOW.
>> Dagen: YEARS WHEN HER
MOTHER SAID IN THE COMPLAINT --
OR HER FATHER COPYING HER MOTHE
MOTHER.
"I HAD SOME CONCERNS AND I WANT
TO FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
GAME PLAN I MAKE SURE WE HAVE A
ROAD MAP FOR SUCCESS AS RELATES
TO OUR DAUGHTER AND GETTING HER
INTO A SCHOOL OTHER THAN ASU."
>> Dana: THAT'S THE OTHER
THING ABOUT THIS, COLLEGE IS NOT
THAT IMPORTANT, FOLKS.
>> Greg: AMEN.
>> Dana: IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE.
ONE OF THE REASONS YOU HAVE
TUITION SO HIGH AS PEOPLE ARE
WILLING TO DO THINGS LIKE THIS
SO THERE'S NO INCENTIVE TO LOWER
IT.
NONE OF US WENT TO A FANCY
SCHOOL.
>> Jesse: WENT TO BERKELEY.
THAT'S PRETTY FANCY.
>> Dana: OKAY, I DIDN'T GO TO
A FANCY SCHOOL.
>> Greg: WE HAVE REDUCED THE
BARRIER FOR LOANS.
YOU HAVE ALL THESE KIDS SADDLED
WITH DEBT.
EVEN MORE BECAUSE IT USED TO BE
THE VIRTUE SIGNAL TO GET A JOB
WAS A BA.
NOT EVERYBODY CAN GET A BA.
SO NOW IT'S A MASTERS.
NOW YOU HAVE TO SPEND MORE MONEY
TO GET A MASTERS IN OUR MASTERS
ISN'T ENOUGH I DO NEED A PhD.
>> Dana: NO ONE HIRES PEOPLE
WITH PhDs.
>> Greg: REALLY?
>> Dagen: GOOGLE WOULDN'T
INTERVIEW YOU UNLESS YOU WENT TO
AN IV.
YOU COULDN'T GET A JOB INTERVIE
INTERVIEW.
IT MADE SENSE TO GO TO WAKE
FOREST.
IT WAS $7500 A YEAR WHEN I
STARTED THERE.
I COULD MAJOR IN ART HISTORY AND
BLOW IT OFF AND NOT GET -- NOT
CARE ABOUT THE EDUCATION.
NOT ANYMORE.
>> Juan: UNLIKE DANA, I THINK
COLLEGE IS VERY IMPORTANT.
>> Dana: I DIDN'T SAY IT'S NOT
IMPORTANT.
NOT THIS IMPORTANT.
>> Greg: IS WHERE YOU LEARN
ABOUT IDENTITY POLITICS, JUAN.
>> Juan: CREDENTIALING,
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW INCOME KIDS,
MINORITY KIDS, TO HAVE A COLLEGE
DEGREE MAKES A HUGE DIFFERENCE.
YOU CAN QUANTIFY IN TERMS OF
LIFETIME INCOME.
>> Dana: I AGREE WITH THAT BUT
MAYBE MY POINT IS THIS.
GOING TO AN ELITE COLLEGE IS WAY
OVERBLOWN.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANYTHING.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY CONNECTIONS,
FAMILY, NO LEGACY.